watching this season obviously at least
we're gonna in her confessionals made a
lot of claims that people on social
media are on Forest side with watching
it back what was the most frustrating
scene for you the frustrating thing was
for 10 months I had to sit there
and
not say anything
and she never said what it was that I
said so when I went to apologize to Kyle
and then Lisa's there like I I thought
to myself I mean I obviously said okay
but then I thought why am I apolog that
was frustrating to me why am I
apologizing to her yeah
you know
she certainly didn't seem we had a
I just cannot I can't believe that she
would turn things around
and do what she did yeah when she was
agreeing and looked at me and said I get
it I get it you're preaching to the
choir I mean come on right
um it has been incredible to watch you
stand up uh not even just for yourself
other women that have why will even
though I'm just a small part of the show
if I see somebody that's doing something
wrong to someone I don't care if I've
never met them before I'm going to stand
up for you yeah I'm gonna go no no
um the women like Lisa Vanderpump even
your sister
um that have you know mentioned or have
had issues with Lisa have they reached
out to you kind of thank you for doing
that
um let's see yes yes and if the show
stays the same same cast would you
consider coming back
I don't think so no no no not not with
the same time
thank you so much thank you